le froid a fait une nouvelle victime
sans abri de 58 ans est mort la nuit
dernière en plein centre ville de
belfort
plus que jamais la question de
l'hébergement des sdf est posée et
catherine vautrin a reçu cet après midi
des membres des enfants de don quichotte
et ce alors que le campement de cette
association installée depuis une semaine
le long du canal saint martin à paris ne
cesse de s'agrandir séverine bourgault
guillaume barbier c'est devenu leur
village leur campement depuis dix jours
le long du canal saint-martin le nombre
de tentes se multiplient au niveau des
tentes on est arrivé avec 6 avec 100
tentes
on les a installés chaque côté du canal
les premières soirées elles n'étaient
pas toutes remplies j'avoue au fur et à
mesure elle est bien logé qui nous ont
rejoints et des sdf
aujourd'hui c'est plus du double près de
250 tentes quelquefois occupé par deux à
trois personnes
une communauté qui s'organise tant bien
que mal avec le soutien des riverains
mangez jamais mes vêtements ramener un
soutien matériel mais aussi morale dans
la rue on signe la charte du canal saint
martin un document dans lequel les
collectif réclame l'ouverture de
structures d'hébergement
moi je suis complètement solidaire je
l'inviterai quartier je connais bien le
quartier je peux donner tout ce que tout
ce que j'ai fait tout je ne suis pas
tellement fortune m voilà une solidarité
limité face au problème de l'exclusion
que les tentes du canal saint-martin ont
permis de rendre visible sur 4000 places
il doit pallier complète et alors je
savais encore des guerres
la poussette blondieau rennes cet après
midi le ministre de la cohésion sociale
catherine vautrin à réaffirmer la
mobilisation du gouvernement devant des
bénévoles du collectif mais a nié le
manque de place aujourd'hui la question
qui se pose n'est plus une question de
classe aujourd'hui sur paris à 350
places qui sont encore disponibles en
hébergement c'est beaucoup plus sur les
formes d'accueil et sur l'accompagnement
que l'on peut apporter
selon l'association emmaüs france un
million de personnes seraient
aujourd'hui privés de logements et
100000 serais à la rue